hey guys Ryan right here hi there I'm
Veronica so we're back for these [ __ ]
Mortal Kombat videos are you fight are
you kidding
no there's a brand new one Jason
Voorhees it's only one minute long are
you [ __ ] serious yeah just so you
know for the video where I did have to
leave to throw up I did another video
where I prove I'm not a [ __ ] that's a
long-ass video but you should look for
that one it's all the brutalities just
throwing that out there anyway Jason
Maury's from Friday the 13th he's in
this game DLC character let's do this
don't get any blood on me
you
this is a waste of my time
noises man
yeah I go to lip-sync okay um you just
totally surprised me with that that was
the goal genuine reaction that's not
fair dude
I spent like 20 minutes watching that
crap with you
mmm have I not proven myself you have
but a lot of people call me a [ __ ] so
as many videos as I can do with you or
we're both in the same shot for the
entire reaction that would make me feel
a lot better thank you
yeah it's actually kind of scary having
Jason Voorhees in there it makes it feel
like a horror game it really pretty
audio this time yeah it's very brutal
very brutal if you want to view more of
our opinions on this game you should
check out the other 17 videos that fans
have asked us to do so yeah you can go
there there's plenty to say about it
okay I'm excited to play as Jason
Voorhees because he is a horror movie
classic character and it does add a
level of fear in Jason Voorhees actually
fits in quite well with this world it
makes sense to have a slasher kind of
killer in there okay okay well if I was
into that sort of thing I would agree
with you I think they should get
real-life serial killers involved in the
games then I feel like that would please
the most of America oh if we can get
like like Ted Bundy richard kuklinski
Jeffrey Dahmer you know if we can get
those people in the games and you get to
play as them that make a lot of people
happy sometimes like I just kind of die
inside when I when I hear you say things
like that I die inside every time you
look at my penis the pointing and
laughing is just obnoxious
after a wild Veronica I've seen black
[ __ ] calm in your search history on your
laptop what were you talking about black
cop calm how did how did you know how do
I know because it's Tyrone Magnus's
website Gare Martin and coolly sometimes
appear on there they're a gay couple
yeah kid Gators always like yeah stick
it in my ass oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ]
and time well it's always like yeah look
at my big black cook I'm done going
along with this job it was the best joke
I could have come up with him sorry I'm
sorry we didn't go on a date tonight if
you guys are new to the channel you can
subscribe to the real rejects Veronica
has a channel too does a lot of acoustic
covers and vlogs but she's been really
consistent with the acoustics lately
should check it out and you can follow
us on Facebook Instagram and Twitter
where we're trying to get product
placement by getting a certain amount of
followers so I'm trying to promote [ __ ]
right now what's around here Oh
clear eyes I wouldn't mind getting
product placement from clear eyes clear
eyes really works you know it works for
many things a everyone knows you know
you might be tired you might have
allergies clear eyes you might go to see
a family member before that you smoked a
bunch of weed clear eyes you might be
jerking off and then you come in and it
hits your eye clear eyes the mess is
brought to you by Ryan Wright and
Veronica